today i'm going to be taking you through
my 15 best strategies
for reducing your phone use hopefully
you'll find some of these valuable and
you'll be able to start implementing
them
today to spend less time on your phone
number one sleep with your phone outside
of your bedroom if i could only give you
one strategy to take away from today it
would be this
in fact i'd go as far as to say that i
think you get a 10 to 20
increase in quality of life simply by
making this change we've all been there
can't sleep on a night time and you know
that booty pictures and funny cat videos
are only three feet away so you roll
over you open your phone
and then three hours later it's 4am you
hate yourself and you've ruined tomorrow
before tomorrow's even begun keep your
phone outside of your bedroom take the
charging cable now
and put it somewhere else put it in the
kitchen put it in the living room put it
in the hallway and just
charge your phone there overnight you're
not going to want to wake up without
charge on your phone
and if you don't move the charger you
cannot have it next to your bed
this is by far the easiest strategy for
reducing your phone use it'll improve
your sleep it'll mean that you get
better starts to your day
just do it number two have a phone free
morning following on from sleeping with
your phone outside of your bedroom
another amazing strategy is to not use
your phone for as long as you can on a
morning
ideally until you're stepping out of the
door to begin your day instead of
starting the day in a reactive state
you're being proactive you get to decide
what you're going to do with your
morning without being
sideswiped by whatever's trending on the
internet or whatever silly group chat
messages
we'll wait until later in the day there
is no reason that you need to check your
phone first thing in the morning so just
don't do it number three turn off all
notifications especially group chats the
phone is there for you to use
not for it to use you and certainly not
for other people to just step into your
day if you imagine that you were sat
down
having dinner somewhere and somebody
just came over and sat at your table
and started talking to you interjecting
between you and the person that you were
with you'd feel like they were being
really rude by leaving notifications on
your phone that is precisely what you're
allowing the entire internet to do to
you not only that
but for the most part group chats aren't
even sending messages
to us we're getting a notification that
someone has talked to someone else
and that is interjecting into our day
it's one time that you need to make this
change go to your settings and turn off
notifications for everything which
doesn't matter
you may have your daughter on imessage
you may have your mum
on messenger or whatever it might be
feel free to leave those on but there is
not a group chat in history
that you need to keep notifications on
for there might be a little bit of
residual anxiety about turning off
notifications what if i
miss an emergency what if there's
something serious going on if it's that
serious someone will ring you
honestly by doing this almost nothing
will change
other than the fact that your day
doesn't get annihilated
by people just sending you random stuff
from the internet number four
log out or remove apps which you use
excessively this has been a really big
one for me
adding in the friction of having to log
back in when i want to use instagram or
facebook or twitter
is just so effortful it forces that
intentionality
so that i can't just randomly decide to
open it and then tumble into a scroll
hole and just that mindfulness gap that
little bit of a break
forces me to hold back do i actually
want to use this do i actually need to
be on instagram
probably not i can't be bothered and
i'll put it away have a think about the
apps that take the most time it's
probably going to be facebook twitter
snapchat
instagram tick tock if you logged out of
them
what would actually change would
anything matter at all probably not
number five
use desktop versions of apps this is
such an easy change especially if you
have to be in communication with a lot
of people
because everything that you do on your
phone you can also do on your laptop
there's not really any reason for you to
have your phone out
and that leads us into number six keep
your phone
out of sight and out of reach when
you're at your desk the proximity
of your phone to you is going to be a
direct function of how much you're
distracted by
if your phone is within sight you will
almost always pick it up and if your
phone is within reach
you'll definitely do the same just leave
it in a drawer leave it in a locker
keep it somewhere that you can't get to
and you won't be able to use it it
sounds so obvious but that's because it
works
if your phone isn't within arm's reach
you can't use it when a task gets hard
at your desk you're naturally going to
look for something to distract you and
if your phone
is in arm's reach that's the first place
that you're going to go number seven use
voice commands as much as possible i
wasn't a massive fan of siri when it
first came out i thought it was clunky
and she didn't understand my accent and
always mistranscribed things when i was
telling her but it actually permits you
to spend a lot less time on your phone
there's
not much now that you can't do by
dictating to your phone and especially
if you've got a pair of airpods or any
other wireless headphones
you can be doing anything especially if
you're having a phone free morning
routine you might actually need to call
somebody but not want to open up your
phone and get sucked into the vortex
that is all your notifications number
eight
use wireless headphones as far as i'm
concerned apple's airpods are the best
product that they've ever created
and this is because it permits you to
use your phone whilst you don't have it
in your hand
on top of that you're unencumbered
you're untethered from your device
you can walk around your kitchen while
you're cooking or prepping or doing
whatever it is
still listening to a podcast still
listening to an audiobook you still get
to consume your content but you don't
actually have to have your phone within
reach just the same as having our phone
away from our desk not having our phone
within arm's reach when we're going
about our day-to-day business
makes it much less likely that we're
going to pick it up so by using wireless
headphones it means we don't even need
to be near it number nine
always use your phone standing up this
sounds a little bit odd but makes sense
when you think about it behaviorally
when you are comfortable when you are
sedentary you're more likely to stay
in the position that you're in so if
you're on your phone sat down on the
couch watching tv or laid in bed
likely it is because you're quite
comfortable that you're just going to
continue going adding in this
environmental friction is the same as
logging out of your apps or deleting
them and having to reinstall them it
just makes you question do i really want
to use this it forces us
to be intentional with our phone use if
you're sat down or laid in a comfortable
bed
you're going to keep on going through
your phone forever but if you know that
you're supposed to stand up
every time that you use your phone are
you really going to make that effort
just so that you can check what's
happened on instagram number 10 have a
hard stop for phone use at night if you
can consider
this the intermittent fasting of phone
use so we've restricted how long it's
going to be before we pick our phone up
on a morning and then we're going to
restrict how late it is that we use our
phone on a night by restricting the time
period within which we can use our phone
we're inevitably going to reduce
our screen time one of the best rules
i've found for this is to have a
behavioral trigger that i stick to and
after that i don't use my phone so i
tend to have a shower on a nighttime
after i have a shower which is about
two hours to 90 minutes before i go to
bed i don't use my phone this could be
having an evening meal it could be
taking the dog for a walk it could be
picking the kids up from
soccer practice whatever it doesn't
matter the point is that you set
yourself a rule and you know that after
that particular behavior has occurred
you no longer use your phone the
negative effects of blue light and using
a screen before you go to bed
are massive they will make your sleep
worse they will play around with your
melatonin release they will play around
with your dopamine levels and your
cortisol
it's just a bad time obviously this ties
in perfectly with leaving your phone
outside of your bedroom so you can have
a behavioral trigger
walking the dog going for a bath
whatever it might be 90 minutes to
two hours before you go to bed plug your
phone in wherever it's going to stay
overnight and that's it
hands off number 11 never use your phone
in a parked car this
is something that absolutely infuriates
me when i see it in myself
and in other people you set off early or
just about on time and you rush and you
worry about getting yourself somewhere
and then when you get out of the car
just before you do you decide to open up
your
phone you're sat in a nice warm car it's
cold outside it's raining you can't be
bothered to go at the gym just yet
and then before you know it you've spent
10 minutes on that and you're late again
you just rushed through traffic and
nearly killed five people
in an effort to make it on time to sit
and look at snapchat this is a really
easy fix and leave this on at number 12
which is
always pack your phone in the boot of
your car it's simply not worth it to
have your phone within arm's reach when
you're driving just because you're in a
moving vehicle doesn't mean that your
brain realizes
it shouldn't be tempted to pick your
phone up as you're sat at a set of red
lights or stuck in a traffic jam not
only is using your phone when you're
stationary still illegal
but your brain doesn't know to put the
phone down when you start moving again
another thing to consider is just how
much stimulus do you need
you're already driving in a two-ton
missile down a road
at multiple miles per hour perhaps
listening to a radio or a podcast or an
audio book
do you really need to be able to look at
the screen as well you can use your time
in the car
as a perfect opportunity to spend some
time away from your phone
without the possibility of using it and
by leaving it in the boot it's not going
to be an option number 13
move icons away from your home screen
the home screen now especially since
ios's most recent 14.0 update
is so customizable you can put widgets
on there which i know everyone on
android has been talking
about for forever but you can finally
customize your phone
to service you in the way that you want
my home screen is super super simple
i've taken all of the icons that i no
longer need and the apps that i don't
want myself to use
and i've hidden them i've got to scroll
for five different pages
until i can access even the app library
you can also remove apps from siri
search so if you pull down from the top
they won't come up every single step
that you take toward making
accessing apps that you don't want to
use more difficult is going to benefit
you it's a 10-minute job to rearrange
your home screen into a way that works
for you
rather than against you and downstream
from that it's going to change the
entire way that you use your device
number 14 have a screen time widget on
your home screen this
allows you to see just how much time
you've spent on your phone every time
that you open and
unlock your device you're going to have
this big number telling you
this is how you're getting on today this
allows you to self-regulate your phone
use much more accurately
you're not subjectively trying to
remember how you've got on today
and over time you can track the trends
of how all these different strategies
are
impacting your time on screen number 15
have a phone sabbath this is something i
did for most of the weekends in 2020
and it really benefited me taking a
sunday and not touching my phone
at all meant that i actually looked
forward to getting to the end of the
week because it meant that i could work
on stuff that i've always wanted to do
but i never feel like i have time to i
was journaling more i was reading more i
was meditating more
i was able to go and train i was
spending time with friends and leaving
my phone at home
so that i could focus on actually
engaging with them you can see the tech
sabbath in a similar way as not using
our phone before a certain time on a
morning and not using it after a certain
time on a night by restricting the time
period within which
we use our device inevitably we're going
to down regulate our use
so there you have it my 15 best
strategies for reducing your phone use
most of these tactics are based around
distancing yourself from your device or
creating brightline rules which are easy
to see when you're sticking
to a final suggestion i have is to
remove self-judgment from your phone use
behind
every swipe and bong and press is an
army of the world's
smartest behavioral scientists backed by
the most complex algorithms and the
biggest companies in
the world they understand your
motivations far better than you do and
their sole goal
is to keep you on your phone so yeah
perhaps you're a little bit upset
at how much time you've spent on your
device today but it's not exactly a fair
fight and berating yourself isn't going
to help thank you very much for tuning
in let me know if you think i've missed
any strategies
or tools that you use to reduce your
screen time in the comments below
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you